[Music]
[Applause]
hello dear friends Welcome to our
question and answer program I'd like to
know this is a weekly feature where you
send us your questions we do the
research and then we answer those
questions on the air and hopefully the
answers are acceptable to those who ask
them uh I want to give you the email
address where you can send us your
questions you'll see it on the screen
TVM tv.org once again
TVM
tv.org I want to remind you that we
receed many many questions question s
and we're not able to answer them all
immediately we put them in line in order
the order that we've receive them and uh
we eventually will get to your question
and we will answer it so keep tuning in
and uh you will have an answer to your
question I have with me uh Pastor David
Salasar who is on our staff he's in
charge of our Spanish speaking work here
at Secrets unsealed and some TV it's
always wonderful to work with you Pastor
Salasar uh and uh would you please have
a word of prayer we always have to pray
before we open God's word absolutely let
us
pray gracious Heavenly Father we thank
you for another day and another
opportunity to study your scripture and
your word we humbly ask that you will
give us your holy spirit so that we may
be able to understand and express your
words and the answers that may bring the
person those that are listening closer
to you we ask now that you will speak
through us and again that the words that
are spoken here may bring Clarity light
to those who are s searching the
scriptures in the truth we pray this in
Jesus name amen amen well we have a very
interesting question it comes from dawn
uh there's no location we want to
encourage everyone to please uh if
possible tell us where you're sending
the question from it's really helpful to
know uh the reach of Secrets unsealed in
some TV uh so if you could uh include
that information that would be helpful
uh here's the question then I'm going to
ask Pastor Salasar to um contribute to
the answer uh hello pastors if a person
deliberately and willingly goes into a
profession knowing that job will require
him or her to work on the Sabbath and
call it doing good when indeed they are
working and receiving a salary is that
the sin of
presumption are we fooling ourselves so
that's that's the question that uh that
is asked and it's not a unique question
it comes up every so often it is a
question that a lot of times people have
uh especially those who might um find it
hard to quit a job that require them to
work on the Sabbath and of course we
know from the scriptures in the in the
law of God the fourth Commandment is
very specific that we have six days to
do all all of our labor all of our work
but this seven days Sabbath is the day
of rest the day of uh dedicating it to
the Lord to connect with him to commune
with him now uh why is the question you
know given because as I mentioned a lot
of times we have this situation where we
are finding ourselves in a job that
requires to work on the Sabbath and we
might justify it uh because let's say
that the job is in some matter that it's
of service to the community or the
service to to the well being of the
country what not you know and so
sometimes we think well you know if I'm
working as a physician for example maybe
working on the Sabbath it's okay well I
think you have to be very careful with
that Concept in the sense that yes we do
need Physicians that we do need nurses
and we do need uh individuals that are
caring for the sick and the needy on on
the Sabbath day Sabbath that's not you
know possible to to be withhold from
from attending and helping but by
choosing to
you know knowingly and willingly to work
on the Sabbath and put yourself in the
schedule to work receiving the income
receiving that salary you are breaking
the Commandment another experience you
know would be when you are
unexpectedly called to do something
let's say you are you know you are not
planning on working but you were called
because there was no one else and you
had to come and work as a physician for
example to save the life of somebody
that's a different experience and even
in that situation the seven day Sabbath
is not Men's Day anymore it's not a day
for you to do you your own pleasure so
any income and I believe this is maybe
and you probably Pastor will help
understand even more but I believe that
if you are working and making money on
the seventh day Sabbath uh for your work
specific you are indeed taking that for
your own instead of and it should not be
given to you but should be given to the
Lord I think prophecy kind of mentions
that the money receive on this holiday
hours should be given to the God's work
that's the councel advice is given so uh
now if you are to think of that way that
the the hours that you spent helping
someone in the day of the Sabbath are
those hours spent for uh your own
increase that I believe will be a sin
but if you are spending doing something
good and not increasing your personal
wealth on the seven Sabbath there's a
different story I think the key to to
this question is if a person
deliberately MH and
willingly other
premeditated goes into a profession
knowing that the job will requiring he
require him or her to work on Sabbath
which would be that work of a physician
the work of a nurse you know medical
personnel uh but it would also include
like for example a law enforcement
officer M you know that's a profession
where it is very very difficult to
observe the sabbath you probably could
get the Sabbath off from your boss but
it would be a lot more difficult so uh
the bottom line is that um if you do
choose like you were mentioning a a
profession that that requires you on the
Sabbath to do good to others any
remuneration needs to be returned to the
Lord as an offering uh you know because
uh if if you keep it for yourself then
you're working on S of a prophet which
which which is forbidden which is a lot
I mean a sin yeah when it comes to the
observance of the Sabbath I just want to
read a couple of statements here on the
seriousness of uh of this issue of
Sabbath observance in in the writings of
Ellen White volume four of the
testimonies page 249 she wrote at the
very beginning of the fourth precept God
said remember knowing that man in the
multitude of his cares and perplexities
would be tempted to excuse himself from
meeting the full requirements of the law
or in the Press of worldly business
would forget its sacred importance six
days Thou shalt labor and do all thy
Work the usual business of
Life here's the keyot for worldly profit
or
pleasure that's key yeah once again the
usual business of life for worldly
profit or pleasure is not talking about
helping other people or not keeping the
money you know that's a different story
uh these words are very explicit MH
there can be no mistake yeah and then
she even goes stronger she says it is
the grossest presumption because the
question asks is this not presumption it
says it is the grossest presumption for
Mortal man to venture upon a compromise
with the almighty in order to secure his
own Petty temporal interests it is as
ruthless a violation of the law to
occasionally use the Sabbath for secular
business as to entirely reject it for it
is making the Lord's commandments a
matter of
convenience I am the Lord thy God am a
jealous God she quotes scripture is
thundered from sin no partial obedience
no divided interest is accepted by him
him who declares that the iniquities of
the father shall be visited upon the
children to the third and fourth
generation of them that hate him and
that he will show Mercy unto thousands
of them that love him and keep his
commandments so that is a powerful
explicit statement about uh you know
using the Sabbath uh conveniently or
excusing yourself because you're you
know you doing a job like uh keeping the
public peace or something in other words
you're you're really you're really using
a pretext yes and uh and that would be
presumption and it would be sin and
absolutely pastor and you know it's
important to know that Christ sometimes
we use example of Jesus that he did good
on the Sabbath that he healed people in
the Sabbath but remember that for
example Christ he healed usually just
one
individual you know the cases where he
healed the Sabbath was a particular
situation or position where he was
encountered with the situation and he
healed just one individual he did not go
and heal multitudes on Sabbath uh just
to make clear that it was not you know
he was not going to make his work if he
could avoid it he would not necessarily
do all these things on the Sabbath so
it's it's important to know that it's
not uh the day to entertain ourselves in
working or making profit or any of that
because again is the Lord's day is the
day of rest the day that he wants us to
spend with him and of course understand
better scriptures amen okay well I think
that pretty well answers the question um
yes I think so so let's go to our next
question uh it comes from
Maryland uh once again there is no
location where it comes from and again I
encourage everyone to please let us know
where you're writing from yeah uh so
that we can uh see what an impact
secreton seal is having and where amen
uh okay this is the question could you
please explain Leviticus 27 and:
31 if a man will at all redeem ought of
his tithes or any of his tithes that's a
ought is an Old King James word uh of
his tithes he shall add th to the fifth
part thereof in other words uh 20%
should add 20% to it so what is this
text really telling us it's interesting
that this text it's sort of uh some
people say well does it mean that if a
man wants to retain
or has to retain the the tithe for a
little bit then he has to ra it to the
tithe with a 10 a 20%
increase um this is probably in regards
and and we have to be very careful
because this is remember this is a
Leviticus uh in the time of the economy
of Jewish economy where it
was um it was not necessarily money so
much that is in stake you're talking
about crops and and you know they will
have to tie from their wheat their
barley Etc and so it could be more in
the sense that
um uh if if if it it's what I I've read
from what I was trying to study is that
if there was a need to for example use
some of their grain to re seed the seed
to use it as a seed again
you could you know you could use that to
re populate or Reed or to regrow the
crops and then give uh an increase by
20% in the next uh uh Harvest but it's
it's sort of in regards to this
experience where the person would have
been in order to continue with their uh
crops growing they would have to maybe
use a part a portion that was supposed
to be used for Tiding but this is what
I've read from the understanding of this
verse Pastor B I don't know if you have
something else to add to this you know I
uh usually look up as many Bible
versions as I can of a certain verse
when there's is a question that comes up
and um from the Contemporary English
version I think that the sense is very
very clear it says if you want to buy
back this part of your Harvest say that
an individual wanted to wanted to uh uh
get back the the corn to use for
seed he could buy that back but then he
would have to in his payment he would
have to add 20% yeah and so the
translation says if you want to buy back
this part of your Harvest this is
Leviticus 27 the same verse it's a
paraphrase but it gives a sense uh if
you want to buy back this part of your
Harvest you may do so by paying what it
is worth plus plus an additional 20%
yeah yeah so I think that uh what it's
saying is you know if you want to buy
back the tithe that you would have given
for a certain crop because you needed
seed yes then you could buy it back but
you would have to add another 20% and
the Lord mentions right the verse before
verse 30 30 there is the the condition
for this to apply only the tithe of the
land in other words the crops what's
seed if you needed that seed to be
bought as you mentioned so it was not
applicable to cattle or to riches or to
any of these any other element except
the seed because it was it might be
needed to grow but it had to be under
the condition that he had to repay with
a 20% increase or double right obviously
you could not give 20% of a cow right no
you could this is why is important you
know in context to understand that this
is speaking of the specifically in the
sense of the seeds of the land the
grains yes
exchanging uh one type of seed for
another type of seed and adding 20%
corre that was what God EST yes so is
not in any way implying that we are to
retain the tithe and and some people may
use this to say you know well what if I
retain the tithe now and pay it later
you know double whatever but that's not
the concept because the the this is is
specifically dealing in a in a condition
of seed and grain not
money very good I hope that that's
helpful you know read us some
contemporary versions of the Bible uh
you know many of them are actually
paraphrases or uh Dynamic translations
but sometimes they help us understand
the sense of what the verse is actually
trying to tell us um I use paraphrases
and in Dynamic translations sometimes to
help me catch the gist of texts that uh
you know as you read them in the King
James version because of the uh ancient
language uh you know many times you
words uh are not clear like for example
where this uh this person is quoting
from the King James right if a man will
at all redeem ought yeah of his tithe
well that means any of his tithe yeah
with context so it's an old word you
know that is made more clear uh by our
use of the language these days amen by
the by the way I'm not demeaning the
King James version no of course not
because that was the language that was
used back then yes yes indeed uh okay so
what's the next question that we have
the next question um we have uh it comes
from um
dney and it says the following I have
inst struggling with anointing services
that is creeping into the churches today
it was not done for the sick but whoever
wishes to is it
biblical or does the J conference
recommends it what is your view on it
he's speaking of anointing services that
are being done in some Churches it seems
at least in the area where dney is from
or he's at and it's not for the sick but
whosoever wishes to be anointed now now
is this biblical so these are the
questions and and you know this is a
good question Pastor because you know we
have probably we have verses of course
in James speaks of James you know to
speak of having the elders come and pray
over the sick and anoint them anoint the
individual the sick individual so uh
usually that's how has always been you
know for for a minister to to be brought
or the elders to be brought to pray an
anoint the individual that requests and
wants to be anointed to go over a
sickness but what if it's not for a
sickness is that something that is
biblically acceptable sound I know we
have anointment in the past for the
priesthood for example and for the Kings
but anything else besides that is that
something that could be done today well
you know I've always been
uneasy about uh anointing places yes you
know there are certain places where for
camp meeting you know they go from room
to room and they anoint the room uh you
know I don't find anything in the Bible
uh that would condone uh anointing rooms
or anointing anointing objects yes uh
you know it's always anointing
individuals MH uh maybe it' be a good
idea to read the passage about anointing
in the New Testament James chapter 5 and
uh beginning with verse
14 that is important
here is any sick among you let him call
for the Elders of the church and let
them pray over him anointing him with
oil in the name of the Lord and theay
prayer of faith shall save the sick and
the Lord shall raise him up and if he
had committed sins they shall be
forgiven
him okay now many times we add things to
the
text for example um you'll hear people
say anoint them with lots of oil on the
head like you I had somebody who said
you know why do we just put a little oil
on the forehead of the person why don't
we just pour a total flask of oil on the
person well the fact is the text says
anointing him with
oil it's not saying that have to anoint
with a lot of oil uh another thing is
you know we almost have a view of
anointing like the Catholic Church uh
which is Extreme unction which is called
These Days the anointing of the sick
that the person has to be deathly ill on
their deathbed yeah and uh you know we
need to go pray that the the Lord will
raise up that person it doesn't say is
anyone deathly sick here uh you know but
it does deal with people who are ill MH
and by extension I would say there are
people who are ill emotionally as well
yes uh not only physically but
emotionally that's just that's also a
disease right and so I would say that if
an IND individual comes and uh they have
some emotional issue that they want God
to resolve or they have some physical
issue that would fit within the
parameters of this of this passage uh
but as far as anointing places and
anointing objects and things like that I
don't find that by extension in the text
I know pastor and I think that is
important because you know maybe
sometimes people may feel that it has to
be like you said only when somebody's
extremely ill or you know is in the
hospital ready to die or something like
that that's when you can actually anoint
but biblically speaking anybody that's
sick and it could be as you mentioned
emotionally
uh physically sick you know that needs
that experience and in most importantly
because the promise here for the
anointing service is that the Lord can
raise him up and he could be in the
second coming and also more importantly
or or more interesting enough for the
person is that he who has committed sins
they shall be forgiven and it almost
reminds me Pastor Bor of the experience
of the man with py who was enabled to
come to Christ and his friends brought
him to Jesus and when Christ saw the
faith of them and they you know brought
him through the roof they opened the
roof of Peter's home and they brought
him down Christ saw the individual and
before he healed him he actually talked
with him and told him your sins are
forgiven the healing that he wanted the
most was the healing of his heart I mean
the knowing that he was forgiven so in
some cases the The Experience because it
might not bring the person back to
health but at least we know that they
have the Peace of in their hearts that
got their sins have been forgiven and
they can be at peace with God and so
this is really one of the most important
aspects of anointing and I think that if
it's done with the this concept in mind
you know that Christ is willing to
forgive their sins and yes the plan he
desires to raise him up even at you know
at the latter day when he comes at the
same time this will be a very solemn
experience a very sacred uh ceremony if
you will not something that is going to
be done you know just for emotional for
show you know and this is where I feel
that if it's done in that way if it's in
some way or another in a church service
or whatever done to appeal just to
emotions and people you know I want to
who wants to be anointed and that kind
of thing I think that's taken away from
what this is a service to be done for
Ellen White also emphasizes that the
before the person is Anointed yeah their
life needs to be examined right and they
they need to be challenged if the Lord
heals you will you follow the Lord's
will will you be obedient to the Lord's
will yeah uh if the person says yes then
you can you can say well not only is the
Lord forgiven you uh the Lord going to
heal you if it's his will but also the
Lord is going to forgive your sin which
is a greater disease right and so uh we
can never be presumptuous however yeah
we can never say Lord you know we're
praying and you've got to heal this
person elsewhere in his book James says
that we should never say I'm going to do
this I'm going to do that we should
always qualify it by saying if the Lord
Wills amen and so when we anoint a
person we don't make demands we say Lord
you know we're following the biblical
counsel we are anointing this person you
got to heal this person no because the
Lord Knows Best what that person needs
what the best procedure is and so we
should always at the anointing service
ask the Lord uh to to do what his will
what is best for that person and Pastor
I think with what you just said we
really have answered um the question in
the sense that it's not just whoever
wishes to be anointed there has to be a
commitment to to follow the lord you
know fully and consecrate their life
fully to the Lord for that to be of any
effect for that to be of experience uh
you know it's if you just want to be
anointed just based on an emotional whim
you know I think that's really uh
mistaken what the concept of anointing
is and I think that if that's the case
that may happen in a church or so or a
setting that is probably contrary to
scripture okay well uh very captivating
discussion about anointing thank you so
much for joining us here at secrets on
seal for program I'd like to know may
God bless you tune in next time and May
God to be with you and keep you in his
care
[Music]